in seven seconds AI designed these
so what does that mean for us as
Architects and designers does it mean we
will be redundant and AI is the future
of architecture well today we're
answering that exact question by using
mid-journey and interior AI to Define
where AI sits right now in 2023 as a
tool and as the future of architecture
what's going on guys my name is David
tomich I'm a registered architect here
in Western Australia and let's dive
directly into this video with Will AI be
the future of interior design so to
assess this we basically use
interiorai.com which is a free public
resource you can jump onto right now on
any web browser upload an image and let
it do the work for you we ran through a
couple scenarios with interior AI a
couple of them were interior yes and a
few of them were exterior just to test
the capabilities of the software we used
interior AI first before we moved on to
Mid Journey just for the simple fact
interior AI is free mid-journey is paid
at the moment so let's run through these
scenarios relatively quickly we started
with an interior office fit out that we
recently completed the office fit out
was quite nice but we uploaded it to
Interior Ai and gave it two different
prompts one for minimally stick and one
for a modern fit out both of the results
that are produced were pretty lackluster
so from the very first exercise I
wouldn't be too scared if you're an
interior architect test interior AI
further we actually took a photo of this
exact office and killed all of the
lighting so it looks pretty basic we
gave it the exact same prompts as we did
for the other interpretation the images
here were again terrible they had
absolutely no value and they weren't
really doing too much more to the space
they were just kind of uplifting the
saturation and increasing the tones so
overall this interior AI software for
the pictures and images I had used as
example wasn't really making me fear too
much for my job but what happens when we
let the AI Run free with the exterior
will AI replace architecture to test the
capabilities of AI against architecture
as a whole we uploaded one render to
Interior AI as a starting point this
render is a real life project it is
under construction right now and if you
want to follow along you can check out
the journey in my Instagram profile down
below all the links are in the
description and I'm sharing it in my
highlight reels looking at the three
images It produced it did an overall
okay job It produced generic building
design on a site that some actually look
like they could fit on the site others I
don't know where it found these angles
from and the third one well it looks
like that site continues 100 meters to
the right so all of these examples
provided some value I guess to the
overall architecture as a starting point
it provided some sort of guidance as how
you could adapt reuse and potentially
copy another Arctic style and it didn't
really provide the level of detail that
Architects are paid for it didn't
understand the experience and knowledge
needed to design something it basically
cut copied pasted and produced a pretty
picture so from this first test I am in
no way shape or form worried about my
job however AI is advancing very very
quickly and mid-journey takes it to a
whole nother level let's start by taking
this render it is a very simple render
it is a very basic render of amassing
form more so than anything I asked
mid-journey to convert it into a modern
Farmhouse and I gave it a few more
prompts I said modern Farmhouse black
design some great landscaping and a
sports car in the photo so I gave it
quite a bit of detail to go off now the
design is in no way shape or form
equivalent to what we produced
originally you'd have to do a lot of
tweaking a lot of changing to make this
work and it wouldn't fit the parameters
of the site but it was able to produce a
very nice modern Farmhouse that if you
ask that to produce that prior to any
knowledge of the actual starting point
you could have used this as a decent
precedent study and gone I like this
shapes forms and then I'll use it to
actually design something the best part
about mid-journey is you can ask it to
create more variations of a version you
like so let's take one of these examples
from that black Farmhouse and ask it to
regenerate now we're able to see that
it's starting to understand the context
of the imagery a little bit more it's
pulling more information and it's
getting closer to what could be feasible
on site so if we look at the very last
image generated you could actually
completely gut this project and reshape
it to suit This Modern black Farmhouse
obviously the Landscaping Contours site
mapping none of it works it would be
nothing like this image when you were
completed but hey it is still a very
valuable exercise and a great starting
point nonetheless now we've established
mid-journey is a little bit more
powerful than interior AI on the
exterior for obvious reasons so we throw
in the same image some simple
comparative words that we use on
interior Ai and mid-journey spat out a
few different results some of these
architectural forms shapes and
expressions I have seen real life
projects of I would definitely design
something like some of these examples as
well so it's starting to actually
interpret the architecture and evolve it
and adapt it based on the prompts with
the right prompts with the right tools
potentially mid-journey could be an even
more impressive tool for the
understanding and fundamental analysis
of sight but not the actual design the
problem with mid-journey is if you start
throwing the wrong prompt in it's going
to throw the wrong images out so this
example where I wrote people walking in
the scene it took it to a whole nother
level it basically created a futuristic
commercial building that people were
walking into so it took the wrong prompt
and latched onto that to create these
beautiful images finally I wanted to
find out could you actually use your
archicad model your Revit model whatever
model you were creating as a 2d Line
work and let me Journey interpret that
with no Prejudice allow it to use its
creative AI technology to create
whatever that wanted so I took a couple
screenshots out of arcad straight line
work of a project that I'm working on
and then I threw it into mid-journey and
gave it very little prompt to see what
it could produce and how it would
actually interpret that data
the final result is nothing like what I
would have expected so what was a single
story building perched on top of a small
Mound with a tennis court underneath
turned into a variety of different
projects it elevated it from a single
story to a multi-story apartment complex
billion dollar mansion so what's the
verdict will AI replace you as an
architect in 2023 AI is definitely a
powerful tool that's progressing and
will be used more and more in the design
journey of professionals as it actually
develops and becomes better give it
another 12 months maybe 24 and it will
be an incredibly powerful tool that all
Architects will be using across the
world however at the moment it is simply
a copy paste procedure it is finding
images from other people mashing it
together and going here you go none of
this works on a realistic site and yes
the human interaction will still be
required for a very very long time to
come anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed the video there's more similar
to that just the side of me if you love
the video hit that subscribe button like
always I'll see you next Monday